Once Upon a Time you all lived together  then the wars came  and you ran off into your little corners  of the world  now you're scared for your life  all you have to do is Pledge Your Law  all kneel before King Kano  [Music]  [Applause]  yeah my eyes  [Music]  kenshi Takashi want me the greatest  fighter to ever exist  I will teach you to use your senses to  live not to die to be the best warrior  take your stance  let's protect Earth realm and end this  right now this is my fight  souls are mine  did nothing  to challenge good time to die  against those with power no one stands a  chance  is it is it just me or is it getting a  little bit nippy out here  he's here  and there is nothing you can do to stop  him  [Music]